on est bien que deux choses et mon amie
la rose me l'a dit ce matin à new moore
je suis baptisée de rente ai
je me suis épanoui
il
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit émir la semaine
dernière nous avons assisté à la
première répétition de la troupe au
grand complet cette semaine nous vous
emmenons à la découverte d'adlink y
tient le rôle du petit émir mais
écoutons tout d'abord andré morin le
responsable de lire sam de la ressource
bonjour dont je m'appelle andré morin je
travaille au centre de la ressource et
je gère un petit peu le service dans
lequel est scolarisée adeline en classe
de 5e actuellement au collège
donc là on aborde maintenant la mise en
scène et on aborde des choses un peu
plus technique sur le plan de la
communication en particulier donc
l'avocat du lean elle a un vrai
potentiel on l'a vu aujourd'hui avec les
premières répétitions
mon rôle ça va être justement un petit
peu de faire passer un petit peu tout
ces funestes dont la mise en scène a
besoin pour qu'elle puisse donner la
pleine mesure de ce qu'il est capable de
donner en langue des signes
parce qu'elle a vraiment un vrai
potentiel on va essayer de faire en
sorte qu'elle puisse l'exploiter au
maximum
tentons donc chez adeline à la
découverte de son univers et de sa
famille
je m'appelle un délit je suis sourde
j'ai 13 ans et demi j'habite à sainte
marie je suis sourde peu profond je
n'entends rien mais je sens les
vibrations
on peut aussi la musique pour moi c'est
simple quand je rencontre des personnes
sourdes c'est facile mais avec les
intendants c'est un peu plus difficile
la communication parfois c'est compliqué
moi je n'ai pas de problème je me sens
soudain je me sens bien
parfois on sent qu'il ya des entendants
qui nous rejette la relation est
difficile parfois il ya des entendants
qui comprennent les sourds parfois non
moi je suis sourd parfois je me dis
c'est pas la peine d'avoir des relations
avec des entendants qu'est-ce qui me
rejette alors maintenant j'ai l'habitude
je comprends les entendant qu'ils
veulent être avec moi et ceux qui me
rejettent
oui moi j'aime bien faire du théâtre
avec des handicapés c'est pas grave
les sourds ou les autres handicapés on
est tous pareils on est handicapé on est
ensemble on se sent bien
voilà la première fois c'était un petit
peu difficile maintenant j'ai l'habitude
ça va chacun on communique on échange
avec lisa oscillant tendance à se passe
bien toutes les deux on mime ensemble
voilà
c'est maintenant au tour de thomas de
nous en dire un peu plus sur sa soeur
donc je suis le frère de guinée
ce qui est de la relation entre elle et
moi c'est pas vraiment changé je pense
d'une relation frères et soeurs qu'on a
tous les jours parce que on se parle on
communique de notre à notre manière
peut-être mais pour pouvoir communiquer
avec elle parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas facile de parler avec elle si on
signe pas parce que ben elle son langage
c'est le langage et sin est donc bien
pouvoir communiquer avec elle j'ai signé
j'ai appris à signer pour que l'on
puisse tous les deux
discutait normalement qu'elle me
comprenez que ce qu'elle me comprennent
donc même si elle est sourde
bon on a on a notre manière de parler
d'eux de se dire des choses même si on
se dit ah notre manière mais voilà quoi
on se comprend elle sait ce que ce que
je lui dis même si je lui dis pas
vraiment parlant mais voilà donc pour
moi c'est une relation normale de frais
dessus
comme nous le voyons entre adeline et sa
famille et c'est une véritable histoire
d'amour
alors là je suis pas fana d'adeline et
je suis artisan je travaille surtout
lille et je fais de la location de
matériel c'était très difficile pour moi
d'accepter en fait très après avec le
temps avec moi la pause on a travaillé
ça autrement et on a vu les choses on a
pris la chose comme elles étaient et
aujourd'hui on la voit devant nous très
émerveillé pour nous ça ne nous donne
que du bonheur ben déjà on a su qu'elle
était sourde elle a vu et 9 mois donc à
partir de ce moment là il a fallu se
relever parce qu'on tombe et il faut
prendre le temps d'intégrer son enfant
parce qu'on a une petite fille rêvait et
puis on se retrouve avec une petite
fille pour laquelle il va falloir se
battre se bat pour plein de choses on se
demande comment ça va se passer est ce
qu'on va réussir c'est tout un
questionnement et puis après vient le
temps de se mettre en route
et puis il n'y a pas de question à se
poser à ce moment là on ne se pose plus
de questions on se met debout et on fait
ce qu'il a à faire pour avancer pour y
apporter tout ce dont elle a besoin
donc c'est un investissement personnel
et ça transforme la vie de la famille
c'est clair mais
jusqu'à présent elle nous a donné
beaucoup de joie et on a découvert grâce
à adeline des choses merveilleuses et
elle nous apprend des choses tous les
jours l avis d'adeline dans la société
c'est difficile et le regard des autres
ça fait mal ça fait mal heureusement il
ya aussi des personnes qui sont bien
qu'ils sont intelligentes qui sont
ouvertes d'esprit et qui arrive à venir
vers adeline même sens avoir signé en
mimant ou en voilà et ça passe alors le
petit émir c'est la grande aventure pour
cette année puisque deviner très motivés
elle a toujours eu mais tout ce qui
était à elle a toujours aimé jouer et a
toujours aimé se déguiser donc pour nous
ça a été une grande surprise va quant à
elle et entraîne médias maman tu sais il
ya un projet de théâtre et tout avec les
autres enfants de tous je lui ai dit
écoute vas-y située à et vas-y donc ça
lui apporte beaucoup de joie
c'est sa passion est donc pour nous
c'est naturel c'est naturel qu'elles
qu'elles aient eu envie de faire le
petit miens voilà donc c'est une belle
histoire en plus et puis elle est
investie elle est volontaire même s'il
ya une petite appréhension ça lui
apporte que du bien et pied juste eu
accès ça va ça va l'aider beaucoup plus
encore à se sentir bien
c'est sûr et certain vu comme lors du
captalat et pour tout ça qu'on avait
entendu au début quand il était petit
aujourd'hui de l'avoir comme ça il faut
le la cccc nomme ici là vraiment on voit
vraiment avec un handicap on peut
s'adapter sans problème aujourd'hui
vingt quand je le vois comme ça ben
voilà quoi
c'est une plume on peut être père mais
bon on a un coeur comme comme tout le
monde s'y passe et on voit sa fille
grandir et c'est comme ça c'est des
moments on se sent seul moi je me avec
la famille on s'est senti seul un moment
donné qu'on a mais après on voit que
bout il ya quand même la bosseuse qui
nous a donné la main nous a permis
d'avancer de voir les choses autrement
et bien aujourd'hui pour moi c'est puis
il ya plus de mille ans dire que voilà
elle est allée comme sale et elle va
grandir leur à ces difficultés comme
tout le monde je n'attendais pas de la
voir comme ça aussi
si dynamique faut dire que c'est quelque
chose de vraiment ça fait un baume au
coeur quoi ça ça donne une joie de vivre
de se sentir bien et surtout de voir
aussi les gens qui sont dans les mêmes
difficultés dire voilà on pas vers ces
gens là parce que ça veut dire ça c'est
ça nous donne une force d'avancer autres
moi est de voir les choses autrement
vraiment d'avoir la corne également des
hommes on est une famille on a des
points faibles comme tout le monde quoi
bien dire les choses comme mais sinon
vers ces mullins et adeline avec sa
petite soeur qui vient de naître
actuellement salle a donné une vie
très forte et c'est une joie pour la
famille mais aussi pour bien dire mais
tu sais pas comment il est bah oui c'est
comme ça c'est la vie c'est la vie c'est
c'est la vie c'est ma famille
après ce joli moment en famille qui nous
a permis de mieux savoir qui et aline
nous vous donnons rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour la suite des répétitions
et une partie de basket riche en
émotions à très bientôt
non